and finally new rule if we're going to
have a new roaring 20s let's not repeat
the mistakes of the last one
i i keep reading that america is poised
for a roaring 20s 21st century edition
a repeat of that decade a century ago
when just like now the united states
emerged from a pandemic
ready to party as if there was cocaine
in the coca-cola
which there was there was in the 20s yes
and now after a year of masking and
distancing i know i'm ready for the
party and
i imagine millions of others are also
itching to engage
in risky behaviors like air travel
sharing a dessert or tweeting what you
really think
and why not the 20s was an especially
exciting time the economy
doubled the masses could afford a car
women stopped wearing 16 layers of
clothing
no dream was too big charles lindbergh
became the first anti-semite to fly solo
across the atlantic
babe ruth hit a home run 575 feet hung
over
with gonorrhea while eating a pork chop
and joe biden started running for
president and
and the stock market was a game where
everybody was a winner
but we all know what happened next the
roaring 20s became the broke-ass
30s it turned into a nightmare with the
great depression the rise of fascism and
worst of all
an endless stream of musicals about
sailors
and looking at the economic factors
right now it feels like we're back in
that headspace that will never run out
of cash as long as the fed doesn't run
out of ink
i'm just saying if we're going to do a
new roaring 20s
let's do it this time without the two
things that made the last one suck
prohibition and a depression at the end
of it
i am no money expert i only turn on jim
cramer to scare away the birds
but it does seem like the market is a
little divorced from reality these days
it's odd that the real economy has been
full of news of unemployment
bankruptcies and going at a business
sign since covet hit
and yet the s p is up 76 in that time
it can't go on forever we can't all win
it's not the ticket machine at chuck e
cheese
a share of gamestop isn't really worth
more than a share of toyota
to bail ourselves out of that depression
we spent over 10 years
over ten years six percent of our gross
national product
to get out of covid we spent in one year
26 the way we're handing out money you
would think it had an expiration date on
it
in 2008 when the global economy was on
the edge of collapse
congress passed what was considered a
massive bailout
of 700 billion so massive over a hundred
protests broke out across the country
the occupy wall street movement was born
now
the word billion is so last decade
congress has passed 6 trillion to fight
the war on coven
2 trillion more than we spent to win
world war ii
you know the big one four years of
desperate fighting
against a murderer's row of bad guys
all over the world and under it
not to mention this thing was kind of
expensive to make
all that in today's dollars four
trillion
this six trillion
so look the other thing we have to do in
the new roaring 20s is end the drug war
this time
a little slow on that stoners
but there's donors but seriously this
time can we have the big party without
having to worry about getting arrested
for doing the drugs that keep the party
going in the first place
because
because in the 1920s america banned
alcohol for reasons which are still
mysterious to me
hey we're about to throw this giant
rager that goes on for 10 years
make sure no one brings booze
[Music]
so let's get rid of our own prohibition
aka the drug war and go straight to the
part where we admit it doesn't work
the white house it's okay
the white house unfortunately is going
in the wrong direction
what the [ __ ] joe
well you really got to give it to the
drug war it is bipartisan
it was 50 years ago when nixon announced
that drugs were quote public enemy
number one
and told elvis to get rid of them by
taking them all
so much of the rot in our society stems
from our modern day version of
prohibition
the people fleeing at the border that's
the drug war
the record-shattering amount of
incarceration this country does with all
its implications for racial injustice
wasted lives and skewed elections
because so many felons can't vote
that's the drug war other people get it
mexico
legalized weed this month canada did it
two years ago
why are we always the last at everything
now
portugal ran this experiment they
decriminalized all drugs 10 years ago
and they had less than 100 overdose
death overdose deaths last year
we have 81 000. the war is over
west virginia lost
you